[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
صبيحه الاثنين السادس من فبراير استفقنا
جميعا على فاجعه هزت الارض
غضب للطبيعه يضرب بزلزال من الحجم الثقيل
في دقيقتين فقط تنهار السماء فوق رؤوس
ارواح امنه في مخادعها فلا يسلم لا الحجر
ولا البشر
مدن وبلدات كامله دمرت في جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا
وبعد هدوء الغبار تبدا الماساه
عشرات الالاف دفنوا احياء واضعاف عالقون
تحت اطنان الاسمنت بعضهم انتظر اسبوعا كي
يرى النور ويتنفس ليخرج بعدها الى عالم
رحل منه الاحباب الى غير رجعه بينما يقف
هو عاريا يواجه قسوه هذه الحياه وحيدا
مع مرور كل ساعه وكل يوم قصص تفطر القلوب
تروى
ودموع كل من يتابع هذه المشاهد في اي بقعه
من هذا الكوكب لا تجف بل يزداد انهمارها
هبى انسانيه هائله للمساعده والغوث تصل
تركيا واخرى تنتظر فتح حدود السياسه لتصل
لمن عاشوا الموت اليومي لعقد من الزمن في
سوريا
موت فوق موت ومعاناه فوق معاناه
لكن حتى الموت على ما يبدو يكال بمكيالين
انا الحقيقه لا اريد اني اناقش ما هو
سياسي هون في كلام منطقي رغم انه للاسف
بالسياسه تفسد حتى ما هو انساني لذلك حبيت
اركز على ما اراها انا بصيص امل وسط كل
هذا الالم
فلول التكاتف الانسان لكان الثمن اضعافا
مضاعفه
لفتني الحقيقه المشاعر اللي انتبتني ومن
المؤكد انها انتبت الملايين من الناس
وكانه المصاب مصابنا على الصعيد الشخصي
وادركت انه احنا ورغم اختلافاتنا
وخلافاتنا الا انه ما يجمعنا اكبر بكثير
مما يفرقنا
هو ضعفنا البشري وغريزه فطرنا عليها تبدو
بسيطه لكن وقعها اكبر بكثير من وقع الف
زلزال
اذا ما هو التعاطف من وجهه نظر العلم
التعاطف ببساطه هي القدره على فهم مشاعر
الاخرين على المستوى العاطفي ورؤيه الامور
من منظارهم والقدره على تخيل انفسنا في
مكانهم يعني كما يقال انه نمشي بحذائهم
مسافه تميل او ان نشعر بما يشعرون وفي
تعريف اخر التعاطف هو فهم وادراك والتمتع
بحساسيه تجاه مشاعر وافكار وتجارب الاخرين
يمكن هي ما نسميها نحن الانسانيه بتعريف
ابسط انها ما يجعل قلوبنا تتكسر وتعتصر
الما على مشاهد المعاناه البشريه وما
يجعلنا مشدوهين امام الشاشات كبيره كانت
ام صغيره نذرف دموعنا على رضيع ولد للمره
الثانيه في اقل من شهر بعد ايام من مخاض
عسير ولد من رحم ركام بارد من الاسمنت
والحديد في شمال غرب سوريا بعدما فقد
عائلا انتظرته طويلا
او هي ما يجعلنا نغص بحرقه على اب فقد
ابناء جميعا في سقطه لم تستغرق حتى ترفت
عين في جنوب تركيا
هي قوه تدفعنا للتكاثف للتعاون للمساعده
للتضامن والاهم للعيش والاستمراريه قبل ما
اكمل معكم متابعينا الحديث عن هذه الغريزه
الانسانيه الكتير مهمه اللي هي تعاطف بحب
ارحب بضيفتي في الاستوديو اليس بيطار
اختصاصيه في علم النفس والمعالجه النفسيه
اهلا بك يلي يسمعنا في كلام منطقي شكرا
خلينا نبلش بسؤال عام نوعا ما وانا في
معرض بحثي عن موضوع التعاطف اكتشفت انه
بالانجليزي في
حتى مش انه 3 انواع من التعاطف ولكن في
ثلاث مشاعر انسانيه بتتقاطع باماكن معينه
لما حاولت اني اترجمها اترجم كل وحده فيهم
للغه العربيه طلع لي كلمه واحده اللي هي
تعاطف ولكن بالانجليزي هم ثلاث كلمات وهن
يعني مفاهيم مختلفه عن بعضهم وانت تقاطعوا
في بعض الاماكن اللي هي
واللي هو موضوع حلقتنا اليوم التعاطف
والكمبشن صحيح شو الفرق بينهم وهل كيف
بيتقاطعوا مع بعضهم البعض
صحيح انه باللغه الفصحى بعد ما في هيك
تحديد واضح يعني يمكن الاشخاص ذوي
الاختصاص قادرين يكونوا عم بيميزوا بكلمات
كتير واضحه بس باللغه اللي نحن هيك نتداول
فيها
ثلاثه فيهم يكونوا تعاطف فيه يكون اوقات
مثلا فينا نحكي عن شفقه عن عطف عن احساس
مع الاخر بس
بالانجليزي ثلاث كلمات كتير واضحين لانه
صار عليهم دراسات كتير ولانه عزو يميزه
ومفهومهم مختلف عن بعضهم صحيح صحيح
التعاطف يعني الانبا يلي عم نحكي عنه
اليوم هو اكثر ان اشعر مع الاخر ان افهم
الاخر مطرح ما هو شو عم بحس كيف عم بفكر
شو هن الامور يلي عم بتصير معه بلحظتها
وان اعرف ترجم يلي هو عم بصير معه
السمبث يلي كمان فيها تكون هيك بركه عطف
او هيك نظره صوب الاخر شعور مع الاخر هي
موصله انه انا بقدر شو حاسه يعني بتعجبك
حاسس مش حاسسها ولا بجسمه ولا بافكاري ولا
بسلوكه انا بقدر انك مزعوج كتير وانا
بتعاطف معك بشو انت حاسس بس مش شعورك صار
شقفه من شعوري انا
اللي هيك فرق بالكومبشن هو انه انا كمان
فيني اقدر شو الاخر حاسس وفينا يكون عم
بشعر معه بس انا
باخد خطوه لحتى اسهل امور الشخص الاخر
يعني هي نوعا ما التعاطف اللي بيقودنا او
بيدفعنا للمساعده لمساعده الاخرين او
محاوله غوثهم صح واجمالا فيهم الثلاثه مثل
ما حضرتك قلت يتقاطعوا او فينك هون بموقف
معين متل ما راح نحكي بعد شوي بكون عم حس
بالثلاثه سوا طبعا احنا كل حديثنا مستوحاه
طبعا من واقعنا والواقع الاليم اللي عم
نشهده قلنا فتره النا عده ايام اكثر من
اسبوع وربما لما تنزل هاي الحلقه راح يكون
اكثر من ذلك واللي هو طبعا الزلزال
شمال غرب سوريا وجنوب تركيا طبعا مشاهد
مؤلمه جدا ما بعتقد انه اي حدا ما تعاطف
وهو عماله بيتفرج عليها
حديثنا اليوم انا ما بدي يعني اناقش هذه
التفاصيل هاي المعاناه ولكن بدي اناقش هذه
القوه الخارقه هذا
العامل السحري اللي بخلينا فعلا نقدر نحس
بالاخرين وبالتالي نقدر نحاول او بيدفعنا
انه نحاول انه نساعدهم فعشان هيك بطلب منك
اليس تبقي معنا شوي خليني اكمل شرح
لاعزائي المتابعين ومتابع الحديث
عندما نتامل هذه القدره الانسانيه الخارقه
على تذوق مراره الاخرين والتنبؤ بما قد
يشعرون به او بما يمكن ان يتبادر الى
اذهانهم في لحظات الالم او الفرح الخالص
وبالتالي نسعد لفرحهم او نتالم معهم
ونتقاسمهم الحرقه ولو لبرهه قد نظن ان هذا
الشعور طبيعي غريزي شعور مجبول بفطره
فطرنا عليها الله سبحانه وتعالى وانه احنا
جميعا نملك هذه الفطره الا من كان قاسي
القلب
هذا الكلام صحيح ودقيق على المستوى السطحي
الا انه لو خدشنا القشره قليلا لغصنا في
بحر عميق
فلطالما كانت المشاعر الانسانيه عصيه على
المنطق وسرداب لا متناهي من امواج متلاطمه
بترفعنا عاليا نتنشق نسيم البحر تارا او
نغرق سحيقا الى قعر حالك تاره اخرى
حروف الناس ليست ظروفنا ومشاكلهم ليست
مشاكلنا واوجاعهم ليست اوجاعنا فمن اين
لنا ان نشعر بمعاناتهم خصوصا اذا كانوا
غرباء عنا
لكن كما الزبد يذهب جفاء فما ينفع الناس
يمكث في الارض
ولولا تعطفن هذا لما تمكنا من خلق قنوات
تواصل حقيقيه مع الاخرين فهذا التواصل هو
اللبن الاساسيه لتكوين علاقات مبنيه على
الثقه والتفهم ولولا التعاطف كمان لما
تمكنا من حل النزاعات بالطريقه السلميه
وتوثيق العلاقات والتسامح وتعزيز التعاون
فيما بيننا
وبهذه المقادير لا بغيرها تبنى المجتمعات
وتنهض الحضارات وتعمر الارض
اذا ممارسه هذه القوه الخارقه تجاه بعضنا
البعض من مصلحه الجميع لكن ما هو مبهر
وبديع في شعور بسيط مثل التعاطف هو ليس
اثار الايجابيه اللي بنجني ثمار هجميعا
فحسب بل البديع حقا هو كيف بنشعر بهذا
التعاطف على المستوى البيولوجي والعضوي
رغم انه امامنا بكيفيه ذلك حتى اللحظه ما
بيتعدى انه يكون غيظ من فيض
على فكره مفهوم التعاطف بحد ذاته مش مفهوم
بسيط ابدا ولا هو رد فعل عاطفي فحسب بل هو
اعقد من ذلك بكثير وبيحدث على عده مستويات
ولديه كمان عده انواع فمن التعاطف ما هو
عاطفي بحث فعلى هذا المستوى احنا بنشعر
بما يحسه الاخرون من فرح ومن الم وحب وخوف
وهاي المشاركه العاطفيه ممكن انه تكون على
ارض الواقع مثل مشاعر اللي انتابتنا امام
مشاهد الزلزال اللي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
مؤخرا
لكن المشاركه ايضا ممكن انها تكون في عالم
الخيال مثل البكاء حزنا او فرحا على احداث
او شخصيات مسلسل خيالي او الشعور بالتوتر
والخوف امام مشاهد فيلم رعب او اثاره
من التعاطف ايضا ما هو ذهني وعقلي وعلى
هذا المستوى بنكون قادرين على فهم وجهه
نظر الاخرين ونرى ما يرونه
اما النوع الاخير فهو التعاطف الجسدي وهو
انه نشعر باحساس الشخص اللي امامنا على
الصعيد الجسدي كالشعور بالغثيان لما
بنشاهد شخص مثلا يرتسم القرف على محياه
بسبب
منظر مقزز او رائحه احنا حتى لا نجتمع
نرجع لحديثنا ايليس اذا من الواضح انه في
عده انواع من التعاطف اول التعاطف بصير
على عده مستويات زي ما ذكرنا في مستوى
عاطفي جسدي وعقلي
هل ممكن انه احنا نشعر بالثلاثه مع بعض او
هل يعني لزاما انه يكونوا الثلاثه مرادفين
مع بعضهم البعض ان ممكن انه مثلا نفهم
افكار شخص ولكن ما نحس بشعوره او نحس
بشعوره ولكن يعني نحس بشعوره عاطفيا ولكن
ليس جسديا
صحيح مثل ما قلت في ثلاث انواع من التعاطف
في عنا التعاطف الجسدي يعني انا بجسمي
بقدر اشعر فزكله جول اخر عم يشعر يعني اذا
هو عم يوجع راسه بصير انا عندي وجع راس
اذا هو عنده وجع بمعدته بصير انا عندي وجع
بمعدته يمكن هذا الكلام اكثر ما بين الناس
اللي كتير متعلقين ببعض مثلا ازواج
متعلقين ببعض صحيح منلاقي مثلا وهي السيده
حامل
زوجها بطنه عم بوجع هذا في حال انه يعني
يحبوا بعض صحيح وهلا وبتشوفيها كمان عند
التوينز في كتير دراسات على التوائم كمان
بتظهر هذا الشيء يعني بيقدروا لو هن بعيد
عن بعضهم هذا واحده من الدراسات اللي
بتذكرها انه في حدا انكسر اجره من التوائم
وهنا ايضا تكل مش يعني هن توائم متطابقه
الثانيه ما بعرف باي بلد عمل وجع اجر ما
فهم ليه دونك هذا الشيء بيصير هذا هو في
الجسد ان انا مش بس قدر شو معقول يكون
حاسس بجسمه حس بهيدا الوجع
التعاطف الفكره
هو اني انا اقدر بفكره بدون مشاعر ان افهم
هو شو عم بخبرني وهو شو عم يختبر
والافكار اللي عم تجعل باله والصور اللي
هي موجوده بباله يعني لدرجه اذا انا قلت
له مثلا وكانك واقف ببير غميق وعم تتطلع
والمدى كتير بعيد بقلي هيدا تماما الشيء
اللي انا عم فكر فيه يعني اقدر بفكره تقري
افكاره نوعا ما يعني تقرئي افكار الشخص
اللي قدامك او او
ما اسمك رائد افكار يعني قراءه الافكار
فينا انا ما تكوني انت بتعني لي ويكون
عندها مهاره قراءه افكار ما بعرف كمان
قديش هيدا الشي موجود ولا لا بس اني هالقد
انا فكريا حاسس بهالاخر وحاطط حاله مطرحه
انه انا قادر حتى الصوره اللي هو على باله
يوصفها كون انا عم بعرفها وعم بنقلها كمان
اوكي والتعاطف الانفعالي هو الشعور يعني
بيجي حدا
مقهور يعني لنستعمل كلمات كتير قويه مقهور
مذلول
عم بعاني حسخص كل شيء
بدنا نعيش الشعور كانها
صح كانه لا سمح الله انا اللي حدا من
اولادي
لو ببالك هينه بس لما بتحسيها بمشاعرك
بتصيري عايشتيها يعني جسمك بيتفاعل معه
وعقلك بيتفاعل معه كانه حاصله يعني انت
اليوم فيك تعيش وجع اصلا ما الك فيه بعيد
عنك ما بعرف قديش مسافات بس بتعيشيها كانه
وجعك
وهل بيجوا هاي هذه الانواع او المستويات
المختلفه من التعاطف
بلزمن يكونوا بيجوا مع بعض ام انه ممكن
الواحد يعني يحس بواحد ومش بالاخر اوكي
مش لزامن يجوا مع بعض واوقات نحن محتاجين
انه ما يجوا مع بعض يعني نحن بالعلاج
النفسي محتاجين انه نكون عم نعمل بس تعاطف
على مستوى الفكره لانه اذا عملنا تعاطف
على المستوى الانفعالي والمشاعر ما بنعود
قادرين يكون عنا رؤيه موضوعيه واضحه وما
بنعود عم نقدر نساعد الشخص اللي مقابلنا
منشان هيك هم لزامن ما بيجوا مع بعضهم
فيهم بوضع كتير كتير قوي او بهيك علاقه
كتير كتير عميقه مع الاخر او مع وضع معين
نختبرهن ثلاثون بس ما ضروري فينا نكون عم
نختبر حيا الله وحده من هول الثلاثه
لكن كيف بيحدث هذا تحديدا هذا سؤال على
فكره حير علماء النفس واخصائي المخ
والاعصاب والفلاسفه كمان على حد سواء كلهم
اتساءلوا كيف قلنا انه نتفاعل على المستوى
الحدسي مع افعال الاخرين والتي لا تمسنا
اصلا وكيف قلنا انه نفهم وبشكل مباشر
وغريزي افكارهم ومشاعرهم ونواياهم حتى
بدات الاجابه على هذا السؤال تتكشف في عام
96 لما قام فريق علماء ايطاليين بقياده
جياكومو ريزولاتي
وفيتوريو غليز باكتشاف وبالصدفه خلايا
عصبيه من نوع فريد وهم كانوا عم بيدرسوا
ادمغه الفئران باستخدام تكنولوجيا التصوير
الدماغي
لاحظوا انه هاي الخلايا العصبيه بتتفعل
وبتنشط مش فقط لما يقوم الفار بفعل ما
ولكن ايضا لما بشاهد فار اخر بيقوم بنفس
الفعل ومن بعدها تم اجراء دراسات كثيره
على البشر لتطابق الصوره في اجزائها رغم
طبعا فارق التعقيد ما بين ادغتنا وادمغه
الفئران وهون ولد مصطلح جديد في عالم علم
الاعصاب الا وهو الخلايا العصبيه المراتيه
او مرر نيورونز
ادمغتنا مليئه بالخلايا العصبيه وهي خلايا
متخصصه بتقوم ببث وتوصيل اشارات واوامر
عبر جهازنا العصبي المركزي واي من اعضاء
الجسم الاخرى والعضلات ويوجد حوالي 100
مليار من هاي الخلايا العصبيه في الدماغ
كل واحده من هاي الخلايا بتتواصل عن طريق
الموصلات العصبيه مع مثيلاتها ومع خلايا
ذات اختصاصات اخرى
ملايين المرات في كل لحظه وهذا التواصل هو
اللي بمكننا من الحركه ومن الفعل ومعالجه
المعلومات وكمان التفاعل مع محيطنا
بحسب استنتاجات الدراسه فانه الخلايا
العصبيه المراتيه موجوده في اماكن عده من
الدماغ منها القشره الدماغيه المسؤوله عن
الحركه وبالتالي بتم تفعيلها استجابه
لاوامر حركيه داخل دماغتنا ولكن الاهم انه
هاي الخلايا يتم تفعيلها ايضا عند مشاهده
شخص اخر بقوم بنفس الحركه فلو تساءلت يوم
لماذا لما بنشوف شخص اعماله بيتثاقب احنا
كمان بنقوم بالتثاقب لا شعوريا ايضا او
لماذا نقلد حركات الاخرين مثلا لا شعوريا
واحنا بنتكلم معهم او لماذا يقلد الاطفال
تعابير وجه ابائهم فالاجابه هي مر نيورونز
او الخلايا العصبيه المراتيه
بيقول الدكتور ريزولاتي في نتائج دراسته
البشر مخلوقات اجتماعيه بقاؤنا يعتمد على
فهمنا لافعال الاخرين والخلايا العصبيه
المراتيه تمكننا من فهم ما يدور في عقول
الاخرين ليس فقط عبر التفكير العقلاني لكن
ايضا من خلال التقليد والمحاكاه ومن خلال
المشاعر والاحاسيس
فبدون هذا النوع من الخلايا اللي بتمكننا
من رؤيه الاخر بعين عقلنا وقلبنا بنكون
معصوبين العينين وغير قادرين على رؤيه
افكار ومشاعر ونوايا وافعال الاخرين وغير
قادرين على محاكاتها او على فهمها وبفضل
هاي الخلايا العصبيه او الميرارنيز عوضا
عن استخدام المنطق للتفسير
وللتكهن بما قد يفعل الناس احنا بنجنح
لفهم من حولنا ليس بالتفكير بل بالمشاعر
وهي ربما من نعم الله علينا واحد مظاهر
رحمته العديده فينا فلولا هاي المراه اللي
نرى وجوهنا متمثله في وجوه الاخرين فيها
لما ترحمنا ولما ساعدنا بعضنا بعضا ولعشنا
جزر منفصله ولفنينا منذ زمن
[موسيقى]
اذا بهذا الاكتشاف التعاطف هو جزء من
فيزيولوجيتنا ومقاديره بتولد معنا وبتكبر
داخل رؤوسنا منذ ان نرى النور اذا لماذا
لسنا جميعا على ذات القدر من التعاطف
ولماذا من نصفهم بقساه القلب ما بتحركهم
ما بهز كيان غيرهم من مشاعر انسانيه
هل يمكن انه يولد بعضنا بخلايا مراتيه اقل
مثلا او اكثر مما هو طبيعي هل يمكن انه
تؤدي اصابات الدماغ لفقدان هاي الغريزه ام
انها وان كانت فطره رب العالمين لالنا الا
انها برضه بحاجه الى من يسقي بذرتها في
مهدها لحتى تكبر وتزهر
خصوصا وان دراسات لاحقه ركزت بشكل كبير
على الاطفال الرضع وجدت انه شكل التفاعل
ما بين الاباء والاطفال في المراحل
المبكره باثر وبشده على التطور الدماغي
والعاطفي للطفل ففي هذه السنوات الاولى
تزرع بذور التعاطف لتحصد ثمارها بقيه
العمر
الحقيقه اليس انه انا عم بعمل البحث لهذه
الحلقه يعني بعيدا عن المشاعر والدافع
اللي خلاني اصلا اعمل عن هذا الموضوع
تحديدا
اندهشت من فكره انه في خلايا عصبيه متخصصه
اللي هي الخلايا المراتيه اللي بتخليه
بتمكننا انه احنا نشعر مع الاخرين ونتعاطف
معهم على كل الاصعده ويمكن كمان نحول هذا
التعاطف لكم زي ما كنا عم نحكي يعني
الدافع للمساعده والغوث
عن جد انه شيء مدهش جدا
يعني كانه كل حدا فينا عنده هاي التشيب في
دماغه اللي بتاهلنا انه نكون اكثر تعاونا
اكثر فهما للاخرين وبالتالي بيضمن
استمراريه مجتمعنا وبيضمن بناؤه اصلا
بدرجه الاولى ولكن مع هيك اذا بنطلع على
هذا العالم اللي احنا عايشين فيه ما بنشوف
كل الناس متعاطفين
الوقت وهنشوف كل الناس متعاطفين مع كل
الناس هل بالفعل البعض منا خلق مثلا
خلايا عصبيه مراتيه اقل او يمكن اكثر او
انه صار في اي خلل
بدو صار في خلل بالدماغ الانسان ممكن انه
يذهب من هذا التواصل والتعاطف الكبير
ليكون كانه جزيره معزوله لا تشعر باي احد
حولها هل يمكن هذا الكلام يصير وكيف اوكي
راح ابلش بموضوع الخلايا العصبيه المراتيه
بتعرفي كيف يلي بعد ما صار امير وخلص كل
الشعب سماه امير يعني اجوا كتير دراسات
حكوا عن هذا الخلايا العصبيه المراتيه
وبعد ما في شيء باكد انه هي هيدا مطرحها
وهيك بتاثر ويقدروا يعني الدراسات لسه
باولها هي دراسات بس قديش الاشخاص اللي
درسوا واللي انتبهوا
حسوا انه هذا الموضوع حقيقي وحسوا انه فسر
كتير امور علم النفس الاجتماعي وعلم النفس
العياده كان بحاجه يفهمها مثل كانه اجا
هيدا الجواب يقول هون هون الجواب على كل
التساؤلات هنا يسكن التعاطف صحيح وعلى
فكره الادمان كمان انا هذا شيء برضو
فاجاني بانه هي نفس الخلايا العصبيه اللي
مسؤوله عن التعاطف هاي الخلايا المراتيه
ايضا لها دخل كبير بالادمان مع انه شو على
مهام الاثنين مع بعض هذا شو بيقولوا عجيبه
الدماغ الانسانه
معقد جدا اكيد اكيد
كل الدراسات رايحه صوب انه ايه في خلايا
مرئيه وهي اللي من خلالها بنفسر كتير كتير
سلوكيات وتعاطف مثل ما انت قلتها واصلا
قبل ما يكون في موضوع الخلايا كان اذا
بدنا نحكي تطور الطفل كيف بده يتعلم كيف
بيقدر يكتسب مهارات انه يفهم الاخر وانه
يقدر يفوت معه بعلاقه اجتماعيه وانه يفهم
الصحه من الغلط وقامتين امه زعلانه
وقامتين بيوضه بهيدا بهايدا المشوار البحث
صوب هذا الاجوبه كان كثير واضح انه في شي
خصه به
بالتقليد يعني طيب وشو اللي بيخلي هالوقت
هالولد يعمل المراه صح صح يعني انا عم
برجع اعكس شو انا عم شوف ليش برجع باعكس
شو انا عم شوف اول شيء لانه عم بتعلم
لانه انا بحاجه افهم اللي عم شوفه ثالث
شيء لانه انا بحاجه لاخر لما انا عم بعكس
شو عم شوف يطلع ويقول اه هاي في هيك شويه
افينتي يعني شويه
هيك تواصل بيني وبينه فبكسب الاخر يعني
اذا حتى هيك شغله كتير بحبها لما تنقول
انا وانت قاعدين اوكي ومنحس انه هيك في
متل ما بيقولوا فلو ماشي فيك تكوني غيرت
شي بقعدتك وكون دغري يعني ثانيه من بعده
غيرت نفس الشيء فهذا الشيء كمان ميه
بالميه الناس بتقلد بعض لا شعوريا بيحكوا
مع بعض بحركاتهم
باختيارهم للكلمات في بعض الاحيان خصوصا
اذا الشخص عن جد عنده قيمه بالنسبه لالي
او عنده تاثير علي اذا حدا ما بيهمني امره
او حتى اوقات اذا حدا انا كتير مزعوجه من
وجوده
ما بفوت بهذا التقليد الجسدي اذا بدك
فلنرجع على موضوع انه ايه في اكيد اسباب
وخلايا بالدماغ بتاثر على هذا
التعاطف هي ممكن تكون المسبب تبع هذا
التعاطف في ناس عنده الناس ما عندهم ما
معقول يعني نحن تكوينه لدماغ عنا هي ذاتها
بتفرق
بالاكثر والاقل واحد اثنين اللي باثر على
تطوره نموه شي معين بدماغنا او سلوك معين
او طبيعه معينه او
شخصيه معينه هو البيئه التربيه مع مين انا
تواصلت شو كانوا مراكز الاهتمام اللي انا
تعرفت عليها بحياتي اللي انا
انعرضت قدامه عم بحكي انا كطفل لانه بعدين
لما نكبر اوكي فينا نحنا نكون مسؤولين عن
خياراتنا بس نحن وصغار يعني اذا الولد
تنقول ما بحياته عارف شو يعني باسكت بول
ما فيكن عنده اهتمام بالباسكت بول بوقت
اذا مثلا اهله كل الوقت عم ياخدوه على
الفوتبول رح ينمي المهاره بالمطرح اللي هو
فاذا هو ما شاف
وما شهد تعاطف او مظاهر تعاطف
ببيته بعيلته ما بين اهله وما بين اهله
والاخرين هو ما راح يتعلم هذا
ومش بس ما بين اهله لما الاهل يفرجوه لاله
انه هن متعاطفين معه ولما هو يفرجيهم انه
في تعاطف منه يستقبلوا هذا الشيء مش انه
يهملوه او
يسخفوه لما نعزز هذا الشيء انا اناقش على
الاخر عم يتعاطف معي انا الولد وانا
اتعاطف مع الاخر والاخر يستقبل هذا الشيء
بكون عم ساهم بطريقه كتير مباشره بان تطور
هذا التعاطف وبمرحله لاحقه لما اشوف كيف
عم يتعاطفوا مع بعضهم كيف هن علاقاتهم مع
الاشخاص قديش مهم الاخر وشو حس وقدم مهم
اني انا اكون بتربيتك منطلق صوب الاخر
وهيك عاطيه حيز بحياته ان اكون عم بهتم
فيه اذا بدك هذا الانساني وهي بشكل عام
لبيوت اللي فيها محبه وموده ودفء يعني
بتنتج زرع انجح بكثير واطفال انجح واكثر
تعاطف واكثر رحمه بشكل عام ومع هيك بتلاقي
في فروق ما بين الاخوه صحيح يمكن
موضوع حلقه ثانيه اللي هو كيف ممكن طفلين
او شخصين ريبيو بنفس البيت مع نفس الاهل
تحت نفس الظروف من نفس البلد ولكن بيطلعوا
مختلفين عن بعض مش بس بشخصياتهم حتى
بمبادئهم في بعض الاحيان
وهذا ينطبق كمان على موضوع التعاطف بتلاقي
بنفس البيت اللي الاطفال فيه ريبيو بنفس
الاخلاق على نفس المبادئ بتلاقي في اطفال
متعاطفين اكثر بكثير او ناس عندهم هذا
الحس عالي من اخواتهم الاخرين اللي ربيوا
بنفس الطريقه كيف ممكن هيك هذا الشيء اللي
بنحكي عنه على تاثير اذا بدك الجينات يعني
التكويننا نحن البيولوجي عنا تنقول
خلايا مسؤوله عن موضوع التعاطف في عنا
ابعاد كتير مختلفه كمان مرتبطه كيف نفكر
كيف نحس مع الاخر هل يا ترى انا
قادر ان اعمل هالانطلاقه صوب الاخر او لا
انا اكثر ربيت به هيك شوي كاركتور هيك
بركه من عزل بركه مش كثير هاممنا شو عم
بيصير برات اطاري انا
دونك كل شيء جسد اكيد كتير بياثر وكل شيء
يعني قد ما تقولي نحن عايشين بنفس البيت
ومع نفس الاهل في فروقات بالتربيه ما في
كمان
تلحظيها على حسب يعني يمكن الظروف
والمرحله العمريه اللي كانت الاهل بمر ميه
بالميه لما جابوا اولد وفي فرق بين اول
ولد علاقتي مع اول ولد والثاني والثالث
واللي بعده بعد في شغله بحب انه هيك نحكي
عنها هي انه كمان الدراسات اثبتت انه
البنات
عندهم قدره اعلى من التعاطف من الصبيان
بعد ما قدروا يعرفوا مزبوط ليه هل يا ترى
هن الهرمونات يلي بتفرق بين بين الرجل
والمراه البنات ايناس عندهم قدره على
التعاطف اعلى من الجنوب وسمونا عاطفيين
ولكن للاسف بياخذوا وبياخذوا هذا الموضوع
ضدنا
مش شيء يحسب لالنا يعني كائنات
يعني برايي ويمكن انا شاهدتي مجروحه
هو ما يبني يعني هذا هادي هي اساسات
البناء لاي مجتمع اكثر من اي شيء اخر صحيح
صحيح تخيلينا ما عنا هذا الناس على
التعاطف بيقولوا يعني انه اوقات هيدا
النزعه وهذول الهرمون يلي موجودين ويلي
كتير بيشتغلوا اول ما الست
تحمل وتجيب ولدها هن اللي بيساعدوها تتحمل
كل الفتره الصعبه يلي مرتبطه بالولاده
بخصوصا اول اول اعماره يعني للولد الصغير
فالماجن ما عنا اياها تخيل انه نحن ما عنا
هالمهاره ولا هيدي القدره مثل ما حضرتك
قلت شو بنعمل كيف بدنا نربي ولد ونرجع
بعدين نربي اجيال ونكون عم نساهم يعني
اكتيف بطريقه كتير فعاله ببناء مجتمع هذا
بقودني يمكن سؤال اخر بما انك ذكرتي
هرمونات المراه خصوصا يعني عندما تصبح امم
عندي هيك مراه هذا الموضوع لانه انا حسيت
يعني انا على الصعيد الشخصي انسان شوي
عاطفي
واعتقد انه حصه التعاطف عندي عالي لانه
هذا شيء يؤلمني يعني يمكن اشي
بيوجعني اكثر من ما هو يخدمني خلينا نقول
ولكن حسيت انه زاد كثير بعد ما اصبحت ام
هل هذا الشيء يعني
متداول شيء طبيعي هل احنا بنكون غير عن
فكره المراه والامومه وما الى ذلك هل احنا
حتى حصه تعاطف عنا بيتغير على حسب المرحله
العمريه اللي احنا بنكون فيها
وحسب الظروف اللي بنمر فيها كمان ليكي على
الاكيد بيعيش بنمرق بتغيرات اوكي اذا انا
عندي هذا المهاره عندي اياها وبنميها اذا
انا ما عندي اياها لهيدي مهاره التعاطف
فينا يكون عم بشتغل يعني لانه بكثير اوقات
وبمطار احنا بحاجه للتعاطف حتى ببيئه
العمل تبعنا بس
انها تزيد وتنقص اي معقول انه يكون في
عوامل عم بياثروا معقول واللي اكثر باثر
يعني اذا بدك نقول هي نسبتها عشره ممكن
اللي بياثر هو العوامل اللي حواليها يعني
انا بهذه اللحظه انا تعاطفه عشره بس بهيدا
اللحظه مت عند مناعه نفسيه انا قويه جاهزه
قادره اتعاطى مع موقف يثير هالتعاطف احسن
من اذا انا حساسه تعبانه انا علي صعوبات
فبعيش هذا التعاطف بطريقه شوي اصعب او شوي
اعمق
فممكن العوامل اللي بتحيط بموضوع التعاطف
هي كمان اللي تاثر على قديه عم حسه يعني
مثل ما حضرتك قلت يؤلمني يعني على قدي
الدرجه اني اشعر
بهالاخر المقابله
لكن الخلل في هاي الفطره يبدو انه هو
الاستثناء وليس القاعده ومع هذا وفي شاهد
اخر على تناقضات طبيعتنا البشريه
مش راح ياخدنا طويلا بعد القاء نظره فاحصه
واحده لعالمنا اليوم حتى نستخلص انه
الصوره الحقيقيه للاسف مغايره تماما حروب
صراعات فشل حتى في الاتفاق على قيمه حياه
البشر كل البشر
وتسييس قضايا انسانيه بحته لا تقبل التسيس
وموت مجاني ومعانا بشريه لا يلقي احد لها
بالا
فهل احنا حقا مبرمجون على ان نرى غيرنا من
البشر مشابهون ومماثلون النا بدل من ان
نراهم مختلفون
للاسف ليس بالضروره ابدا هناك من هم
متعاطفون مع مجموعه من الناس دون غيرها
مثلا وهذا طبعا بيعتمد على عده عوامل
تتمثل في كثير من النقاط مثلا نظرتنا
للاخرين يمكن تحدد هل احنا ممكن نتعاطف
معهم او لا ايضا كيف نرى والى ماذا نعزي
تصرفات الاخرين
وايضا على ماذا نلقي اللوم عندما يتعلق
الامر بمصائب ووردات الاخرين
كتير منا للاسف بيوقع ضحيه التحيز المعرفي
وهذا بيجعلنا نعزي فشل الاخرين لخلل داخلي
فيهم بينما منعلق فشلنا احنا الشخصي على
شماعه الظروف الخارجيه واللي خارجه عن
ارادتنا وهذا بدوره بيجعلنا اقل قدره على
رؤيه الامور من منظار مغاير لمنظورنا
الادهم من ذلك انه البعض منا ايضا يرى
الاشخاص المختلفون عنهم بالشكل والثقافه
واللي كمان بعاد عنهم او بعيدون عنهم
جغرافيا بيشوفوهم وكانهم من جنس او صنف
اخر غير بني البشر وبالتالي بيعتقدوا ان
هؤلاء ما بيشعروا او ما بيتصرفوا زي ما
احنا بنتصرف
مثلا كان نراهم بانهم ما بيحبوا اطفالهم
زي ما احنا بنحب اطفالنا او انه ما بصيبهم
الالم من نكبات الحياه زي ما بصيبنا
وبهذا احنا هيك بنكون عم بنجردهم من
انسانيتهم يمكن اكبر مثال على ذلك ما تفوه
به عدد من مراسلي القنوات الاجنبيه في
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا اذا بتذكروا
البعض منهم وصف مشاهد النزوح الاوكراني
عبر الحدود هربا من الحرب بانها ليست
كمشاهد اللجوء اللي تعودنا عليها في سوريا
او في العراق او في الشرق الاوسط او في
افريقيا
ووصفوا هؤلاء اللاجئين الاوكرانيين بان
هذه المره اللاجئون هم اوروبيون هم
متعلمون هم من الطبقه الوسطى
وكانه هم اعلى درجه في الانسانيه من غيرهم
وكانه كمان هذا اللاجئ الاوكراني اشقر
الشعر
واللاجئه الاوكرانيه اللي بشرتها بيضاء
واللي لابسه على الموضه وما بتلتحف بعباءه
سوداء هي كانها انسانه اكثر من اي امراه
اخرى افغانيه او افريقيه يمكن فقدت كل
عائلتها وكل ما تملك
فهل احنا فعلا لا نتعاطف حقا الا مع من
يشبهنا طيب السنا جميعا بشر ومن ذات
الطينه
وهل يصبح لدينا مناعه نوعا ما ضد هذا
التعاطف كلما طالت مده مصائب الناس فمننسى
طيب خلينا نرجع هيك بنظره لعلمنا الحالي
ووقعنا فعلا احنا لما نيجي نطلع بنقول طيب
هاي الغريزه وهاي الفطره الالهيه اللي
ربنا فطرنا عليها
وسخر لنا هدول
الموصلات العصبيه او الخلايا العصبيه
المراتيه لحتى تكون بخدمتنا تخدمنا اكثر
يعني اكثر من اي شيء اخر ومع هيك لما
نتطلع بنشوف حروب ومقاسي ومنشوف ومنشوف
ناس بامس الحاجه للمساعده وما حدا بينظر
حتى لالهم
فبصير الواحد يرجع يفكر وبيقول هل فعلا
احنا على هذا القدر من التعاطف ام انه
احنا نتعاطف مع من نعتقد انه بيشبهنا اكثر
فبتلاقي مثلا الغرب متعاطف بشكل كبير مع
اوكرانيا اكثر بكثير من ما هو متعاطف يمكن
على الصعيد الانساني مع اوكرانيا
والاوكرانيين اكثر من ما هو متعاطف بشكل
كبير مع مصائب بتصيب الشرق الاوسط مثلا او
بتصيب افريقيا صحيح هل مضبوط هذا الكلام
مزبوط راح اقول لك في قسمين انا حابه
اجاوب عليهم راح ابلش بثانه
نحن اذا عم نحكي عن هذا التقليد انت
بتقلدي ناس بيشبهوك بالاول اول ما بدك
تقلدها بدك تقلدي امك وابيك اوكي وبعدين
بتعيشي بمجتمع كمان بتعرفيه فبتصير اهين
لك
تبني تعاطف مع اشخاص بيشبهوك
وبعدين اذا عن جد هيدي القدره هي هيك خاصه
وطورتيها فيك تقشعي انه حيا الله انسان هو
بيشبهني وانه اذا كان باوروبا واذا كان
بالشرق الاوسط هو ذاته بغض النظر عن لون
البشره والثقافه واللغه وكل شيء صحيح بس
هيدي مش كل الاشخاص بيوصلوا لها اجمالا
نحنا بنعيش التعاطف مع الناس اللي
بيشبهونا لان اهين الدماغ بصير قادر يفهم
اسرع الاشياء اللي عم بتصير والجسم يقدر
يتفاعل اسرع مع شي بيشبهه
دونك هيدي هي نقطه بالنسبه لانه الناس
اللي بيشبهونا اثنين
اشياء بتجي مع تعاطف بتاثر اوقات سلبا
يعني اذا انا بتربيتي ربيانه على انه
تنقول ايه بس ما هن الغرب مش فرقانه معهم
نحنا ونحن بدنا نهتم بحالنا عرفتي بصير
فيها ظالمينا او اي شيء صحيح
او اشعر بانسانيه الشخص الاخر الشخص
الغريب اللي عندي حواجز عقليه تجاهه اصلا
ميه بالميه هلا لرد على تاني قسم من سؤالك
هيدي العواقك قدام التعاطف هي كبيره يعني
انا لما بدي اوقف واطلع على الاشخاص اللي
قرروا انه يصير في حروب ويصير في جشع
ويصير في ظلم وما تفرق معهم الاشخاص
اذا بدي اطلع على الدافي عندم تعاطف قديه
عم يستثمر هالتعاطف اصلا قد بيعرفوا
بالتعاطف لانه في كتير ناس درجه التعاطف
عندهم كتير كتير اوقات شبه معدومه
لمطلق سبب يمكن لانه عندهم اضطرابات نفسيه
يمكن اوقات لانه في تاخر عقلي اوقات لانه
في مشاكل بالنمو
فهذا الشيء اللي بياثر يعني مش انا اللي
متعاطف مع الاخر رايح اعلن حرب على بلد
ثاني ما بدنا نشوف
مين اللي عمر هذا اذا بدك قرار الحرب
وراح صوبه قديه هو مقامن بالتعاطف ومؤمن
بالانسانيه ولا لا مش موجودين هاي
المفاهيم عنده في نقطه تانيه كمان مهمه
جدا انه حتى لما نتعاطف مع مصائب الاخرين
خصوصا لما يكون في كوارث كبيره بحس او ما
بعرف اذا هذا الكلام صحيح بحس انه نتعاطف
لفتره معينه بعدين نوعا ما بصير في عنا
مناعه مناعه تجاه هاي المشاهد او نزهه او
ما بتاثر فينا بعد فتره من رؤيتها بشكل
متكرر
ليش هيك بصير ممكن مع انه المصيبه لا تخف
وتطم صحيح واوقات بتزيد يعني
بتصير تقولي عم يمرق ايام زياده وفي يعني
اوقات هيك بتصير القشره دقيقه اكثر بس
لانه اول شيء فيكن تقسموا
يعني انك تكوني بقلب الشغله لفتره طويله
لدرجه بصير كانه عندك تخدير عليها
فهايدي وحده من الامور اذا انا كتير كتير
عم بتعرض
لهيدا الحدث لصعوبات هذا الحدث وانا كتير
عايشه تعاطف مع هيدول الامور بوصل بوقت
خلص بحس انه هيك مثل صار في درجه من
التخدير
اثنين هذه يمكن لا علينا لانه يعني هي
طريقه
لحمايه انفسنا من مدار كثره التعاطف ممكن
في النهايه او مدار اي شيء صحيح اثنين فيه
الشخص اللي يكون بقلب هذا الوضع
يتعب بيعمل بورنو بيعمل احتراق نفسه فهذا
الشخص العامل احتراق نفسي خلص يعني اصلا
ما بقى عنده طاقه يقدمها لاخر هو بحاجه
ليرجع يجمع طاقته ثلاثه بدنا نشوف اذا
اللي نحن عم نعمله هو تعاطف حقيقي يعني هل
يا ترى انا عن جد رايحه اصوب هذا الاخر
بتعاطف حقيقي
ولا لا انا رايحه بس لانه انا بحاجه افهم
شو معقول يكونوا حسوا لانه الصدمه كتير
كبيره لانه بتذكرني بشيء انا اختبرته
بطفولتي فهيك بعيش معه انفعال قوي بس
بعدين بيروح يعني اصلا انطلاقتي صوب هدول
الاشخاص وشعوري بالتعاطف معهم في يوم من
الاساس ما يكون عن جد تعاطف حقيقي فيه
ويكون لاسباب تانيه فلما احصل على الجواب
ولما نرد على الطلب تبعي اذا بدك نفسيا ما
بعود عندي هالميل للتعاطف معهم لهيدي
الاشخاص او لهالاحدث
مشكله اخرى ممكن توقف عقبه امام تعاطفنا
مع الاخرين
وتكمن في حاجتنا كبشر انه نؤمن انه هاي
الحياه اللي احنا نحياها هي حياه منصفه
وانه هذا العالم اللي احنا بنعيش فيه هو
عادل
هذه الحاجه والرغبه بالايمان بانه الناس
يصيبهم ما يستحقون وانهم يستحقون ما
يصيبهم ربما لحتى نخدع انفسنا ونشعر
بالاطمئنان بانه هاي المصائب لن تصيبنا
ابدا
ورغم انه الحياه ابعد ما تكون ربما عن
العدل والانصاف ورغم ادراكنا الواعي لذلك
الا انه الا وعيه دائما بيوجد طريقه
لطمانه نفسه حتى وان كان عن طريق الخداع
وللاسف النتيجه في جميع الاحوال هي لوم
الضحيه بدلا من الجاني
هل شو فائده التعاطف اذا ما دفعنا اذا ما
حولنا لكم زي ما كنا عم نحكي يعني ما
اعطانا الدافع لانه نحاول
نغيث
من يتعرض الى الى مشكله او مصيبه انه ما
نحاول انه نساعد شو نفعه
التعاطف شي كتير مهم لا انت تفهم الاخر
اللي مقابلك وتقولي له انه انا عم بفهمك
لانه في كتير اشخاص بحياتنا بيمرقوا نحن
يمكن منحس انه انا عم بختبر شي بس ما حدا
قادر يفهمني ومنصير نقولها ما عم تفهم علي
او بيركضوا الناس ليقولوا لنا طب اعملي
هيك واعملي هيك
وقدم لك هدول الحلول بس انا ما بكون هيدا
هو حاجه الاساسيه منشان هيك التعاطف هو
شيء اساسي لعنجد افهم الشخص اللي مقابيله
من وين منطلق وشو هي حاجته وشو هو طلبه
واوقات بكفيه للاخر اللي مقابيله انه انا
فهمت عليك
بقدي انه ما بقى يحس حاله وحده
من شان هيك هي بحد ذاتها هيدا الشغله
كافيه وقادره تساعدني بعدين نحط خطه
التدخل
[موسيقى]
بظروف مثل هالظروف اللي هلا نحن عم نمرق
فيها
بكوارث طبيعيه بحاجه يعني ادنى مقومات
الحياه ولا اي مساعده صحيح لا يكفي ابدا
انه بس نفهم ونحس معهم لازم نعمل شي صحيح
ورح اقول لك شيء انه كمان منك بحاجه
تتعاطفى يعني الان التعاطف كانبسه في كمان
تشعري فيه بس تروحي دغري على الكومباشن
عرفتي على المساعده على العمل يعني انا
فينا ما اقعد ما اكون شخص قاعده وعن جد
حاسه بوجعه الاشخاص او عم قول يا الله شو
معقول يكونوا هلا شعروا او هن تحت الانقاض
شو شاعرين بس بقدر روح دغري على الكومباشن
بقدر اقول على الاكيد المصاب اليم على
الاكيد هن بعينو عم يتعذبوا لازم اعمل شيء
لازم شارك بالحل اوكي
هل في ناس او انواع شخصيات معينه او
اضطرابات نفسيه معينه بتجعل منها اقل
تعاطفا يعني يقال بانه الشخصيات النرجسيه
غير قادره على انها تحس بالاخرين
بالطريقه الطبيعيه
اوكي في اضطرابات نفسيه على الاكيد ما
بيكون فيها يعني او احتمال التعاطف كتير
قليل فيها
مثل الاشخصيات يلي منسميها حدوديه نسمي
الاشخاص يلي
مش
يعني الاشخاص اللي
ما بعرف شو يعني هيك على حدود
[موسيقى]
الاجرام اذا بدك او على حدود اني اعمل كل
الامور اللي ما بتشبه المجتمع وضد المجتمع
واكيد المجرمين يعني اكيد انه هن ما عندهم
تعاطف ولا ما كانوا ارتكبوا هاي الجرائم
بحقوا ناس
في اغلب الاحيان صحيح هلا بالنسبه
للناس اللي عندهم نرجسيه
بيقدروا يكونوا عم بيطوروا قدره على
التعاطف مع الاخرين بس لانه يعني وللاسف
ويمكن مش للاسف لانه بالاخر راح يطلع لهم
لالهن شي منه يعني انا تعاطف هو من مصلحه
الجميع صحيح بس اذا انا عم بحكي عن حدا عن
جد نرجسي انا بقدر اكون عم بعمل تعاطف مع
اخر اذا انا اليز عندي هذا الشخصيه
النرجسيه فيني يكون عندها تعاطف مع
الاخرين بس بستثمر هالشي وبفعله لانه
بالاخر براسه انا بقنعتي انا راح يرجعلي
لالي بالخير
ساعتها انا بقدر اطور تعاطف مش بس لانه عم
نروح فيه صوب اخر كيف بنقدر نعلم انفسنا
نكون اكثر تعاطفا اذا هذا الدرس ما
تعلمناه واحنا صغار
ليكي مجرد ما نحن عنا هيدا الهم يعني في
شيء فينا رايح ثوب هالتعاطف اوكي يعني اذا
انا بدي اقول كيف بدي اتعلم اتعاطف يعني
انا جاهزه
بنقدر نكون عم نفهم اكثر الاشخاص عم جرب
نسال طب شو عم بتحس شو عم بتفكر عم نجرب
نشوف انه قبل ما نركد صوب النصيحه او صوب
الفعل نسال الاخر هو شو حاجته نجرب نفهم
هالشعور مرئين نحن في مش مرقين نحن فيه شو
بيشبه يعني فينا نعمل هدول التمارين
الصغيره لحتى نقدر نكون اكثر عم نتعاطف مع
الشخص يلي مقبيلنا انكيس من بحال عزناه
لانه رب تعاطف
بس بس تيرجع لي قلبي بعدين منه هذا الشيء
اللي كتير اجابه اذا انا بدي اكون عم ننمي
مهاره التعاطف انا بدي اكون عم بعرف كمان
وين عم بستعملها وكيف عم بستعملها وكيف عم
بنتبه على حالي انا صح بما انك ذكرتي وجع
القلب احنا عم نذكر محاسن وفائده التعاطف
في بناء المجتمعات والتواصل مع الاخرين
والتعاون بس في الها مزالق والها كمان
مساوح
خصوصا مثلا لكثير ناس من اللي بيعملوا
بالقطاع الطبي مش قادره اتخيل يعني ناهيكي
عن مصاب اللي تاثروا بهذا الزلزال من فقد
ذوي من فقد كل شيء من
اللي فقد اولاده كمان مش قادره اتخيل وجع
اللي عم بيساعدوهم اللي هم فرق الانقاذ
الطاقم الطبي اللي بيوصل الليل والنهار
الان علشان يحاول يقدم يعني اي مساعده
كانت في اسعاف هؤلاء طب هذا عبء نفسي كبير
حتى بالنسبه للعاملين في القطاع الطب
النفسي برضو هذا عبء نفسي كبير واحنا
بنصير في هاي الحاله بدل ما نمد يد
المساعده بنصير نمد يدنا نطلب المساعده
صحيح بدي اقول لك انه على طول بالازمات
وحتى نحن اذا بدك بالمجال الطبي بس لانه
عم نحكي عن الازمه عطول بالازمات في فريق
بينزل على الارض
ليساعد
ويشوف الحاجه ويرد وفي وراه فريق جاهز
يستقبله لحتى يساعدوا يفضي يعبر
تيقدر يكفي يعني لانه
نوصل وقت هيدا اذا بدك شو قلتي للانزلاقات
تبع لانه في اشي معروف حتى بالصحن اسمه
الضغط او التوتر التعاطفي صح فلما نوصل
على هذا المرحله لانه في هذا لانه فينا
نعمل احتراق نفسه لانه فينا نعمل تعب مزمن
ما نعرف شو هو فينا نكون عم نعمل
يصيبنا اكتئاب فينا يصيبنا قلق من بعد هيك
تعرض هالقد احاسيس
لصعوبات ومشاهد صعبه كتير وشو بدها
بالمشاهد لاختبارات ناس مؤلمه
فمنشان هيك ان كان بازم كبيره ولا بحياتنا
اليوميه بدنا ننتبه على قديه عم بياثر على
حياتنا الشخصيه صحتنا النفسيه موضوع
التعاطف ولحظه اللي بنلاقي انه لا عم باثر
علينا عم بحملوا معي عبايته عمكن تعبانه
مش عم بقدر افرح بالامور ما عم بقدر كون
اصلا ما بقى عم فينا كن فعاله بالقشره
اللي لازم تكون فعاله فيها بدنا نوقف
وبدنا نشوف كيف بدنا نهتم بحالنا وبصحتنا
النفسيه ونقدر صح نوازن ما بين هذا صحيح
التعاطف الايجابي
وما بين يعني حاجتنا احنا ايضا لحدا
يتعاطف معانا كل حال يعني والحديث لا يمل
ان شاء الله اكون قدرت قدرنا نغطي كل
النقاط اللي ممكن ينحكى فيها في هذا
الاطار يبقى انه نقول انه يعني هذا ليش لا
شيء اللي عم نحكي عنه مقارنه
بما يشعر فيه
في ختام حلقتنا
من الواضح انه جذريا وعلى المستوى القاعدي
هناك عاملان يؤثران على قدره البشر على
الشعور وممارسه التعاطف وامتلاك الدافع
للمساعده وهم الجينات والتربيه او البيئه
فالاباء بورثوا ابنائهم جينات وخصال
بتساهم في تشكيل شخصياتهم ولكن ربما الاهم
في هاي المعادله هي او هو العامل الاخر
وهو عامل التربيه والبيئه فاحنا ما بيتم
تربيتنا من قبل اهلنا فحسب بل احنا بنتربى
وبنتعلم من مجتمعاتنا من ثقافاتنا من
مدرستنا ومن اقراننا
وفي نهايه المطاف الطريقه اللي بننظر فيها
للاخرين واللي من عاملهم فيها هي في
الحقيقه انعكاس اشاهد على المبادئ
والاخلاق اللي احنا تربينا عليها منذ
نعومه اظفارنا فنحن لا نحصد الا ما نزرع
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان
باذن الله
[موسيقى]